I think it's pretty scary.
I mean,
I,
but you know,
it's,
I don't have a lot,
but you know,
it's all,
it all sounds pretty political at the
end of the day.
Um,
and without getting political and all
that kind of stuff,
it just,
I think the big unfortunate thing is,
is that as soon as it starts to hit home
and it starts to affect us,
then there seems to be,
uh,
an effect,
you know,
then there seems to be a reaction if
there's outreach.
But if you look around the world,
this is,
this is normal for a lot of people.
This is actually,
it's surprising that it's even a
surprise to people.
It's shocking that it's a shock.
It's shocking to me that nobody takes
responsibility for,
for,
uh,
you know,
a world that someone in chaos right now
and has been for a number of years.
This is,
none of this is new.
Um,
so that being said,
without getting all dreary and stuff,
uh,
it's been around for a long time and,
I think we all have responsibility.
Yup.
Do you know,
I'm sure it's a matter of time that it
will,
um,
you know,
I think like everything else,
hopefully we'll get through it.
Uh,
when it,
when it does happen,
I hope it doesn't happen,
but I'm sure it will.
Uh,
and all we could do is,
is kind of,
you know,
put our heads down and hunker down,
so to speak,
and do what we have to do to get to get
through it.
Okay.
I don't think we have a choice in the
matter of these laws are getting passed
and,
uh,
and people are being affected and,
and you know,
eventually,
uh,
I think,
you know,
it's a matter of time before,
uh,
before fall,
guys just out outright banned.
Um,
but you know,
this is,
it's call it what you will,
I mean,
some people would say it's risky,
it's irresponsible to do it in the first
place.
All those would say it's responsible to
it.
And Eh,
you know,
um,
in all that being said,
trans fats,
I mean,
the effect that it has on,
um,
uh,
is all politics and it's a matter of,
of,
you know,
standpoint.
I guess,
and all this,
all this is it's a little beyond me.
Just a simple cook,
opening a restaurant in east village
foods
set up clipping friends,
fats.
Anyway,
so it doesn't have an effect on me at
all.
But I understand how a lot of people,
uh,
you know,
a lot of people need to live by fast
food restaurants.
I mean,
it's sometimes the only food that they
can afford.
So I would like to think in a perfect
world that the,
that the fast food restaurants would
take the responsibility to serve the
foods a little bit healthier without the
government having having to get
involved.
Um,
unfortunately it's just not the world we
live in.
Um,
and,
and not gonna,
you know,
I'm not going to be the boy that cried
trans fats,
but will say that,
you know,
it's sometimes desperate times call for
desperate measures.
Obviously
I happened
and I really think about it and I think
it's a matter of evolution.
Evolution takes time.
And the way I think about,
you know,
eventually going into maybe a fine
dining restaurant one day becomes the
opportunity to kind of,
to,
to reign yourself in completely and take
a fine dining approach outside of the
casual restaurants and things like that.
But a fine dining approached by reigning
yourself in and doing,
you know,
Dan Barber I think does it very well.
Uh,
even Michael Anthony does it very well
and there's a lot of shifts that do.
And,
and of course I'm not going to go
through the whole list,
but those are the two that really come
to mind,
uh,
that,
you know,
Cook from the land,
the simplicity and the beauty of the
product.
Um,
you know,
to listen to Dan,
Barbara speak about these things and
his,
his eloquence with it.
It's,
I mean,
it's like,
it's great.
So he's the guy you got to ask,
not me.
I do.
Absolutely.
I mean,
my,
my grandfather lost,
lost
his farm when my father was,
was young.
So there's always that,
you know,
it's in the back of my head.
Um,
and I still have family up in the north
and main that live that are farmers.
Um,
it's uh,
you know,
you do what you can within the confines
of Your Business and you know,
things being what they are and,
and you know,
the economics of a restaurant being what
it is.
Sometimes it's unfortunate that you
can't,
you know,
the difference between an organic egg
and a commercial lake.
Now you look at the way a commercial leg
is raised and you look at the way an
organic egg is raised.
You know,
unfortunately it costs more than three
times.
The organic aid cost more than three
times they commercially raised egg.
So the economics of a restaurant being
what it is and you know,
occupancy costs of restaurants in New
York City being what they are,
there's only so much you could do
sometimes without,
you know,
customers are still price sensitive and
savvy for that matter.
Obviously in New York City.
So you do what you can.
You,
you want to be responsible.
I never want to be a responsible.
Uh,
and hopefully what that means is that
it's something that I can grow into more
and more over time.
Back to the evolution of it.
No,
I think that,
uh,
there's where there's a will,
there's a way,
you know,
uh,
it,
it seems to me that there's so much
infrastructure,
uh,
with,
with commercial farming,
commercial food products that it's easy.
That's an easy cop out,
right?
But if we put ourselves on a path to
kind of get to that point,
you know,
maybe it may take time,
but eventually we'll get to the point
where it is feasible
just called by restraint.
Maybe that last,
uh,
three bowls of ice cream I shouldn't
have had.
I wasn't that fat is the kid.
But,
you know,
I mean there's,
there's,
you know,
I,
I was also a big baseball player and all
that kinds of things.
And,
and,
uh,
I think,
you know,
the,
with the,
you know,
it's,
it's always a concern,
right?
You want your children to be active.
You don't want them to sit in front of a
TV and playing video games.
I don't have kids,
so it's easier for me to,
to,
it's very easy for me as a non parent to
say,
this is what kids should do.
I'm not going to play that game again
because every parent in the world of
tell me what an ass I am.